can you quickly tell the people the
story of Christmas and North oh well I
was amazed I did a lineup for a show
once and it was a there was a royal
presence and the Prince of Wales said
apparently you live in Norfolk is it
right I said why I do have a place is
not not far from sounding room in fact
which was the where the royal family
have a house you know wonder if I said
you should come visit me for Christmas
lovely lovely lovely idea of course I
thought they're more about it and that
Christmas I had a real house full of
friends about 14 people all squeezed
together and I'm a very early riser I'm
very much a lock not an owl and hence I
was up and I was making eggs benedict I
remember distinctly and hollandaise
sauce is a very you know you have to
concentrate you did get the the melted
butter into the egg yolk you have to be
really thin steady stirring the phone
went so I mean somebody adds of that
please somebody will know that all the
14 people showering shagging whatever
they do I picked up on yes and even
frankly I said yes this is he and he
said mrs. Prince of Wales here and
there's up my brain out of my brain sent
a signal to say oh [__] off Rory
[Music]
another part because you always know
when it's someone real another part just
overtook it and when oh well as he said
that I was wondering about taking you up
for that offer for tea I said well that
would be wonderful
what would you like when it's convenient
he said well what about New Year's Day
so I said what that would be fine so I
kind of put the phone down and thought
right so I went into the hall and I
shouted but like Rickon in the young
ones house appeared at the top of stair
heads until I said the Prince of Wales
is coming for tea and then everybody
went oh my god and then there was a
fantastic sight which I could have I
mean I could have photographed I should
have done it of everybody meets you
Laurie hoovering the carpet making -
you're getting ready everything's the
fires burning everything was completely
ready and we're all peeping out to the
curtains like pathetic children like
then all these cars passing written and
then eventually to cars all right Chris
crunch everybody's disappeared except me
so I the doorbell goes and I think I
must play cool otherwise he'll think I'm
really uncool and so I count 15 and the
bell goes again and I open it and he
goes oh hello I hope you don't mind I
brought my wife and there's Princess
Diana comes out to the shadows and was
he's hello Steve hello and everybody
comes down and we have this Tea Party
and it's fantastic and she's wearing
cowboy boots which suits very well he's
not wearing cupboards which suits him
very well it all goes fantastically
everybody's having a great time and then
they go and he says goodbye and she
holds in the doorway and she says I'm
sorry McCain but I'm quite glad we going
early because it's spitting image on
tonight and I could watch it in my room
they hated of course but I love
[Applause]
[Music]
you